Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. When Brutus was about to take his army across from Asia, it was very late at night. His tent was dimly lit and all the camp was wrapped in silence. And then, as he was meditating and reflecting, he thought he heard someone coming into the tent. He turned his eyes towards the entrance, and he beheld a strange and dreadful apparition, a monstrous and fearful shape standing silently by his side.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。当时布鲁图斯正准备将他的军队从亚洲带过来，天色已非常晚。他的帐篷里昏暗微明，整个军营都笼罩在寂静之中。随后，正当他沉思默想时，他以为听到有人走进了帐篷。他向入口处望去，看到一个奇异而可怕的幽灵，一个巨大而阴森的身形正默默地站在他身旁。
He plucked up courage to question it. Who art thou, said he, of gods or men, and what is thine errand with me? And then the phantom answered, I am thy evil genius brutus and thou shalt see me at philippi and brutus undisturbed said i shall see thee so that was dan brown uh his account of the life of marcus juniusutus, assassin of Julius Caesar. Tom, that's a tremendous scene, isn't it? That's foreshadowing Brutus's eventual defeat. Do you think that actually happened? Well, rewritten and, dare I say,
他鼓起勇气质问它。你是神还是人？他说，你对我有何差遣？接着，那个幻影回答说：“我是你邪恶的天才，布鲁图斯，你将在腓力比见到我。”布鲁图斯镇定地说：“那我会见到你的。”这就是丹·布朗，呃，他关于尤利乌斯·凯撒的刺客马库斯·尤尼乌斯·布鲁图斯生平的记述。汤姆，那真是一个震撼人气的场景，不是吗？那是对布鲁图斯最终失败的伏笔。你认为这真的发生过吗？嗯，经过重写，我敢说，
improved by Shakespeare, who makes it the ghost of Caesar himself. He does make it the ghost of Caesar, doesn't he? Yes, so the phantom is just a mysterious phantom, isn't it? It's his genius. Right. So it's kind of the idea that is just a mysterious phantom isn't it it's his genius right so it's the kind
莎士比亚对其进行了润色，他将其改成了凯撒本人的鬼魂。他确实把它写成了凯撒的鬼魂，不是吗？是的，所以这个幻影只是一个神秘的幻影，对吧？这是他的天才。没错。所以这是一种，它只是一个神秘的幻影，不是吗？这是他的天才，没错。所以这是一种
of the idea that there is a supernatural yeah dimension to his character um and reflective of the kind of the um the lurid and dramatic shadows that all the figures in this great drama cast um because they are operating on the the greatest stage of all well this is one of the great this is one of the great tales in all history, as we were saying last time. So last time, for those of you, I was about to say, for those of you who missed it, why would you have missed it?
关于他的性格中有一种超自然的，是的，维度的想法，嗯，这也反映了，呃，在这部伟大戏剧中，所有出场人物所投射出的那种阴暗而戏剧性的阴影，呃，因为他们是在最大的舞台上运作。嗯，正如我们上次所说，这是历史上最伟大的故事之一。那么上次，对于你们中的，我本来想说，对于那些错过的人，你们怎么会错过呢？
Tom took us brilliantly through the conspiracy to assassinate Julius Caesar. The reasons that Caesar was seen as a threat to the Republic, the motives of the conspirators and so on and so forth.
汤姆精彩地为我们梳理了刺杀尤利乌斯·凯撒的阴谋。凯撒被视为对共和国威胁的原因，阴谋者的动机等等。
And Tom, you ended on this fantastic scene. Caesar is lying there, his toga over his face, pool of blood beneath the statue of Pompey, and then he's bundled into a litter by three slave boys and carried away with his, I can't remember, his arm or his leg dangling out of the litter.
汤姆，你以这个精彩的场景收尾。凯撒躺在那里，托加袍盖着脸，庞培雕像下是一滩血，然后三个奴隶男孩把他塞进一辆轿子，抬走了，我记不清了，他的手臂还是大腿从轿子外面垂落下来。
And the liberators, you said last time, they haven't really thought through what they're going to do next. What do they do next? Well, so we've cast Brutus in these deep and supernatural shadows, they haven't really thought through what they're going to do next. What do they do next? Well, so we've cast Brutus in these deep and supernatural shadows, but there's actually something faintly kind of pathetic about his behaviour in the wake of the assassination because he keeps trying to give a speech and he keeps being unable to do so. So his aim when the murder has happened is that he's going to hold the floor and give a speech.
正如你上次所说，解放者们并没有真正想好接下来要做什么。他们接下来要做什么？嗯，所以我们给布鲁图斯涂上了这层深沉而超自然的色彩，他们并没有真正想好接下来要做什么。他们接下来要做什么？嗯，所以我们给布鲁图斯涂上了这层深沉而超自然的色彩，但实际上，在暗杀事件发生后，他的行为有一种隐隐的可怜，因为他一直试图发表演讲，却又总是无法做到。因此，当谋杀发生时，他的目的是要掌控全场并发表讲演。
But there's all this panic and he kind of gets swept out. And then he goes out into the forum and he wants to give a speech to the great mass of the Roman people. And he does give a speech, but there's nobody there because everyone's running panic. This mood of terror grips the city. People start boarding up shops. Antony, you know, who is consul with Caesar, is terrified that he's next. And so he disguises himself as a slave and runs off to his house and hunkers down there. And a very eerie sound can be heard over the streets of Rome,
但现场一片恐慌，他某种程度上被人群裹挟着带了出去。然后他走到广场上，想要向广大罗马人民发表演讲。他也确实发表了演讲，但那里根本没有人，因为所有人都惊慌失措地逃跑了。这种恐怖的气氛笼罩着全城。人们开始给店铺钉上门板。安东尼，你知道的，他是与凯撒同任的执政官，吓得要死，生怕下一个轮到自己。于是他伪装成奴隶，逃回自己的家，并在那里死守。人们可以听到罗马街头回荡着一种极其诡异的声音，
which is the mourning of the Jews of Rome. Caesar had always been their great patron. And so they're kind of mourning him. And the liberators basically don't know what to do. So, so they retreat to the capital, which is, um, one of the hills that kind of frames the forum, the great kind of central space in Rome. And, um, and they hunker down there and they really mess it up because what they should have done is reconvene the Senate, declared Caesar a tyrant, you know, seized control of the functioning of the Republic. But instead they barricaded themselves up in the Capitol and they leave it to Antony to take the initiative. He realises that the assassins are not doing what he had expected to do. You know, he gets off his disguise as a slave, dresses himself up as a consul again, and he convenes the meeting of the Senate himself. And in the meantime, there's been rioting in the streets of Rome, looting and burning and whatnot. And is that because the crowd are angry that Caesar, their great pal, is dead?
那是罗马犹太人的哀悼。凯撒一直是他们伟大的庇护者。所以他们正在某种程度上为他哀悼。而解放者们基本上不知道该做什么。于是，他们退守到卡питолий山，那是环绕罗马广场（罗马的大型中心空间）的山丘之一，嗯，他们在那里据守，结果把事情彻底搞砸了。因为他们本该做的是重新召集元老院，宣布凯撒为暴君，你知道的，夺取共和国运作的控制权。但相反，他们把自己 barricade（封锁）在卡питолий山上，却把掌握主动权的机会留给了安东尼。他意识到刺客们并没有按他预料的那样行事。你看，他脱掉了奴隶的伪装，重新穿上执政官的服装，并亲自召集了元老院会议。与此同时，罗马街头发生了骚乱、打砸抢烧等等。这是因为民众愤怒于他们伟大的好朋友凯撒死了吗？
Or is it because they're merely seizing the opportunity to have a bit of a barney, as it were? I think there's a feeling that no one is in control in rome uh and so of course people will always take advantage of that but most people are just hunkering down and waiting to see what's going to happen right and what happens is that on the 17th of march so two days after the murder anthony convenes a meeting of the senate in a temple that is very close to his house so in his shadow yeah and also uh dolla bella who i mentioned in the first part who is cicero's son-in-law a caesarean very very thuggish greedy unpleasant figure not popular can be very charming when he wants to be but but is is really a very menacing
还是因为他们只是借机大闹一场，所谓的趁火打劫？我觉得人们有一种感觉，觉得罗马没有人掌权，呃，所以人们当然会利用这一点，但大多数人只是闭门不出，等待着事情的发展。好吧，发生的事情是，在3月17日——也就是谋杀发生两天后，安东尼在离他家非常近的一座神庙里召集了一次元老院会议，也就是在他的势力范围内，是的。还有，呃，多拉贝拉，我在第一部分提到过他，他是西塞罗的女婿，一个凯撒派成员，非常残暴、贪婪、令人讨厌的角色，虽然需要时可以表现得很有魅力，但实际上是一个非常具有威胁性的
presence and so his place by the side of anthony is, you know, I mean, it's not encouraging for people who imagine that the liberty of the Republic is going to be restored. Cicero is at this meeting and he proposes an amnesty, which is accepted. So the assassins, the liberators, whatever you want to call them, that they will not be, you know, they will not be prosecuted for Caesar's death. They also, it's passed that the dictatorship will be abolished forever so that's the end of that institution and in the best tradition of the republic they start allocating provinces to various figures and provinces mean that you can go out and throw your weight around and make money by kind of you know looting them or whatever bullying the locals yeah yes and so
存在。因此他在安东尼身边的位置，你知道的，我的意思是，对于那些想象共和国自由将会恢复的人来说，这并不是什么令人鼓舞的信号。西塞罗出席了这次会议，他提出了特赦，并被接受了。因此，刺客们——或者叫解放者们，随便你怎么称呼他们——将不会因凯撒之死而被起诉。同时通过的还有，永远废除独裁官制度，因此这一机构宣告终结。按照共和国最好的传统，他们开始将行省分配给各路人物。行省意味着你可以去那里作威作福，通过掠夺或者霸凌当地人来赚钱，是的，所以
you know various figures pile in so decimus brut, who we mentioned in the first part, had escorted Caesar to the Senate House, loyal friend of his, perhaps even son, but he was one of the conspirators. He is appointed consul in 42. So he will get the consulship in two years time. But he's in the meanwhile, he is given Cisalpine Gaul. And Cisalpine Ga the, it's Gaul on the Italian side of the Alps. So the part of Gaul that borders the Rubicon. Yeah. And that of course is incredibly geographically significant because it comes with, with legions. So Decimus Brutus can imagine, well,
你知道，各路人马纷纷涌入。我们在第一部分提到过的德西穆斯·布鲁图斯，曾护送凯撒前往元老院，是凯撒的忠实朋友，甚至可能是他的儿子，但他也是阴谋者之一。他被任命为公元前42年的执政官。因此他将在两年后获得执政官职位。但在此期间，他被授予了山南高卢。山南高卢是阿尔卑斯山意大利一侧的高卢。也就是与卢比孔河接壤的那部分高卢。是的。这在地理上当然具有极其重要的意义，因为它附带着军队。所以德西穆斯·布鲁图斯可以想象，
you know, I can put the Republic in my shadow going there. Trebonius, who it is said kept Antony from going into the Senate House, he gets Asia and Dolabella. He's confirmed as consul for 44 and he's given Syria as a province. And so all of this looks like business as normal, Republic, you know, the grandees of the Republic dividing it up. However, the assassins make one fatal mistake and shrewd analysts at the time recognise it immediately as a mistake. And that is that they allow Caesar to have a public funeral.
你知道的，我可以把共和国置于我的阴影之下。特罗尼乌斯，据说他曾阻止安东尼进入元老院，他得到了亚洲行省。而多拉贝拉则被确认为公元前44年的执政官，并被分封叙利亚为行省。所有这一切看起来都像是一如既往的生意，共和国的显贵们在瓜分它。然而，刺客们犯了一个致命的错误，当时精明的分析人士立刻意识到这是一个错误。那就是他们允许凯撒举行国葬。
This is a famous and catastrophic moment for them, isn't it? Because it's such a schoolboy era. It's a bit like having a coup and not seizing the TV station. Well, I think it's because Brutus and Cassius think that there has to be compromise, that they have to compromise with supporters of Caesar. And so symbolically, what happens is that Antony and Lepidus send their children as hostages to the conspirators on the Capitol, and then they have dinner. So Cassius has dinner with Antony, Brutus has dinner with Lepidus, and it looks as though, you know, all pals together. I mean, that that must have been those must have been quite awkward um awkward dinner parties you would imagine or maybe not i mean you know these are people who know each other very well and this is what's so extraordinary is that the conspirators
对他们来说，这是一个著名且灾难性的时刻，不是吗？因为这就像发动了一场政变却不去占领电视台一样初级。嗯，我认为这是因为布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯认为必须妥协，他们必须与凯撒的支持者妥协。因此，象征性地，安东尼和雷必达将他们的孩子作为人质送到卡питолий山的阴谋者那里，然后他们共进晚餐。所以卡西乌斯与安东尼共进晚餐，布鲁图斯与雷必达共进晚餐，看起来好像，你知道，大家都是好朋友。我的意思是，那一定是非常尴尬的晚宴，你可以想象，或者也可能没有。我的意思是，这些人彼此非常熟悉，而最不可思议的是，阴谋者们
seem to have assumed that everything has gone back to normal and so they are kind of playing by the conventional rules yeah but anthony you know's a very, very shrewd and ambitious man, as you would expect a lieutenant of Caesar to be. And he recognises the opportunity. And so on the 20th of March, Caesar's funeral, his body is displayed in the forum together with his blood-stained toga. An effigy of Caesar in wax is slowly turning. So, you know,
似乎认为一切都恢复正常了，所以他们某种程度上是在按常规规则行事。是的，但安东尼，你知道的，是一个非常精明且极具野心的人，正如你对凯撒部将的期望那样。他看到了机会。因此，在3月20日，凯撒的葬礼上，他的遗体同他的血衣一起在广场上展示。一个用蜡制作的凯撒塑像在缓缓转动。所以，你知道，
they got it on a kind of revolving pole. And the, the, the wounds inflicted on him by the assassins is, are marked out. The names of the assassins are recited as the body turns. And, you know,
他们把它放在某种旋转的杆子上。随着尸体的转动，刺客们留在他身上的伤口被标示出来，刺客的名字也被宣读出来。而且，你知道，
this is not getting the crowd in a good mood. And this is, you know, this is the famous friends romans countryman lend me your ears speech in shakespeare and anthony reads out caesar's will so there's one detail in caesar's will that he's not tremendously keen on which is that caesar has adopted as his main heir uh his sister's grandson a young lad called Octavius, who we will come to in due course. So Antony slightly kind of passes over that. But one of Caesar's secondary heirs is Decimus Brutus,
这并没有让民众的情绪好起来。这就是莎士比亚剧中那段著名的“朋友们，罗马人，同胞们，请借给我你的耳朵”的演讲，安东尼宣读了凯撒的遗嘱。遗嘱中有一个细节是安东尼不太感冒的，那就是凯撒收养了他的姐姐的孙子、一个名叫屋大维的年轻男孩作为他的主要继承人，我们稍后会讲到他。所以安东尼稍微有点敷衍过去。但凯撒的次要继承人之一是德西穆斯·布鲁图斯，
the very man who has just killed him. And so when Antony reads this out, there are kind of boos and catcalls. And then Antony comes to the gifts that Caesar has left to the Roman people. And these include gardens that he owns that are to be public parks. There are cash donations to everybody. And this obviously goes down tremendously well. Even in death, Caesar is the populist, Tom. Absolutely. Yes.
也就是刚刚杀死他的人。因此，当安东尼宣读这一点时，台下响起了一片嘘声和倒彩声。接着，安东尼念出了凯撒留给罗马人民的遗赠。其中包括他拥有的、将成为公共公园的花园。还有给每个人的现金捐赠。这显然大受欢迎。即使在死后，凯撒仍然是个民粹主义者，汤姆。绝对是的。
And so all kind of, you know, Brutus's kind of garden editorial speeches seem very pallid compared to the red-bloblooded here's loads of cash going by you know we're in a metro kind of stuff um and by the end of it basically people mobs are roaming rome looking for assassins to lynch and this is again a kind of awful episode where they they corner a guy called sinner and they mistake this guy who's actually a poet for one of the praetors who was seen as having been sympathetic to the assassins. And they rip him to pieces, chop off his head and carry it around on a spike. So generally, things are not looking good for the assassins. And adding to the generally apocalyptic mood.
因此，所有这些，你知道的，布鲁图斯那种充满书生气的演讲，跟这些直接发钱的、血气方刚的实惠比起来，显得苍白无力，我们正处在大都会风格的事情中，等等。到最后，基本上暴民们在罗马街头游荡，寻找刺客进行私刑。这又是一个可怕的插曲，他们把一个叫辛纳的人逼入绝境，把这个实际上是诗人的家伙误认为是一个对刺客抱有同情心的行政长官。他们把他撕成碎片，砍下他的头，插在长矛上游街。总的来说，对刺客们来说情况不妙。而且这还加剧了普遍的末日氛围。
So again, Shakespeare in his play has these great lines. When beggars die, there are no comets seen. The heavens themselves blaze forth the death of princes. Mount Etna in Sicily has erupted. And the atmospheric effect of this is, you know, in the days and weeks that follow Caesar's assassination, a cosmic doom seems written in the skies. You know, the sun is blotted out. The skies turn a kind of bruised violet. And people say the sun, you know, is averting its eyes from the wrongs done to Caesar.
所以同样，莎士比亚在他的剧中也有这些伟大的台词：“乞丐死时，不见彗星；苍天自身却用烈火昭示着亲王的死。”西西里的埃特纳火山爆发了。而这带来的大气效应是，你知道的，在凯撒遇刺后的几天和几周里，天空中似乎写下了宇宙的厄运。你知道，太阳被遮蔽了。天空变成了某种受伤般的紫罗兰色。人们说太阳，你知道的，在转开视线，不愿去看对凯撒犯下的罪行。
And one thing we didn't mention, Tom, actually, is that one of the people who was in the city at the time, who we've talked about a lot last year on the rest of history, is Cleopatra, Caesar's former mistress. And she races for the coast, doesn't she? I mean, she recognizes that it's all going to kick off very shortly in Rome and she's better the coast doesn't she i mean she recognizes that um it's all going to kick off very shortly in rome and she's better off going back to egypt yeah absolutely so she scrams off and um meanwhile people looking up in the skies a comet blazes across the sky people say it sees a soul going up to the heavens and so all in all it seems as though the heavens have turned against the assassins so the figure who the figure who provides us with a window onto what is going on at this time, as he's done throughout the last decades of the Republic and the Civil War is Cicero.
还有一件事我们没提到，汤姆，实际上，当时在城里的其中一个人，我们在去年《历史的余烬》中讨论过很多次，就是克娄巴特拉，凯撒的前情妇。她向海岸狂奔，不是吗？我的意思是，她意识到罗马很快就要大乱了，她最好——她向海岸狂奔，不是吗？我的意思是，她意识到，呃，罗马很快就要大乱了，她还是回埃及去比较好。是的，绝对的。所以她飞奔而去，与此同时，人们抬头望向天空，一颗彗星划过天际，人们说那是凯撒的灵魂正在升天。所以总而言之，上天似乎已经背叛了刺客。那么，这个为我们提供了一扇窗口，让我们得以窥见当时发生之事的关键人物，正如他在共和国和内战最后几十年里一直做的那样，就是西塞罗。
We have his letters, we have speeches that he wrote, philosophical meditations, and in his letters, we can see his kind of sense of disappointment and frustration. And so he despairs basically of the assassins. I said in the previous episode that he complains that they had the souls of men, the spirits of men, but they had the foresight of children. And he puzzles at the way that freedom seems to have been restored, but the Republic hasn't, he complains. And so he you know what's he going to do he so he contemplates going to to athens where his son is at the equivalent of university and misbehaving and so he sets off for that gets on the ship storm blows it back in comes back and he gets letters from his friend saying why are you running away and so he kind of feels ashamed and so he
我们有他的书信，他写的演讲稿，哲学沉思录，在书信中我们可以看到他的失望和挫败感。因此，他对刺客们彻底绝望了。我在上一集里说过，他抱怨他们空有男人的灵魂和精神，却只有小孩的远见。他感到困惑的是，自由似乎已经恢复了，但共和国却没有，他抱怨道。所以他，你知道，他该怎么办呢？于是他考虑去雅典，他的儿子在那里上相当于大学的学校并到处胡闹。于是他动身前往，上了船，风暴把船吹了回来，他又回到了罗马。他的朋友们给他写信问：“你为什么要逃跑？”于是他觉得有些羞愧，因此他
comes back to rome and even as many of the conspirators are thinking, well, we should probably leave Rome, it's getting awkward. And Brutus, don't forget, is the urban praetor, so he's meant not to leave Rome, but he ends up heading east. Cassius does, many of the other conspirators do. Decimus Brutus heads northwards to try and take possession of Cisalpine Gaul and the legions that are up there. Cicero remains in Rome, and he ends up becoming the chief spokesman for the cause of the kind of traditional constitution, the traditional way of doing things. And for a man who is, he's very elderly by this point. And as I said, you know, he's not a naturally brave man. This is his kind of great last swan song, his attempt to rally enthusiasts of the Republic against what he sees as the threat
回到了罗马。正当许多阴谋者在想，嗯，我们大概应该离开罗马了，这气氛越来越尴尬。别忘了，布鲁图斯是城市行政长官，所以他本不该离开罗马，但他最后还是向东逃去。卡西乌斯也是，许多其他阴谋者也是。德西穆斯·布鲁图斯则向北进发，试图占领山南高卢以及那里的军队。西塞罗留在了罗马，并最终成为传统宪政、传统行事方式事业的主要代言人。对于一个当时已经年事已高的人来说——正如我所说，他并不是一个天生勇敢的人——这是他伟大的最后绝唱，他试图将共和国的拥护者凝聚起来，对抗他所看到的、仍然挥之不去的
of tyranny that still lingers because although Caesar is dead, his lieutenant isn't. And Cicero identifies the great danger to the Republic as being Antony. Just before we go into Antony, Tom, first an observation, then a question. So the observation is that the behaviour of the conspirators really reminds me of another group of conspirators we talked about last year, the plotters in 1991, who deposed Mikhail Gorbachev. And they wanted to get rid of Gorbachev, but they had no real, they wanted to sort of turn back the clock in this vague, nostalgic way to what they saw as the glory days of the Soviet Union. But they had no concrete plan for doing it. Now, one thing that they did try to do when they had that putsch was they brought troops into the center of Moscow.
暴政威胁。因为尽管凯撒死了，但他的部将还在。西塞罗将共和国的最大危险认定为安东尼。在进入安东尼的话题之前，汤姆，首先是一个观察，然后是一个问题。观察是，阴谋者的行为真的让我想起了我们去年讨论过的另一群阴谋者，即1991年废黜米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫的政变者。他们想除掉戈尔巴乔夫，但他们没有真正的，他们想以这种模糊的、怀旧的方式将时间倒流回到他们眼中的苏联辉煌岁月。但他们没有制定具体的计划来实现这一点。现在，他们在发动那场政变时确实尝试做的一件事，就是把军队调到了莫斯科市中心。
And so my question is, do the conspirators have any reservoir of troops that they can call on to restore order in the city and impose you know martial law or whatever or have they not even given thought to that they have um there is a legion on the island in the tiber that is under the command of lepidus yeah and lepidus of course is caesar's master of horse his deputies that is a threat to them but there are legions that have been assigned to decimus brutus in his role as putative governor of Cisalpine Gaul. However, these are Caesar's legions. And although Decimus Brutus had served under Caesar in Gaul, again, it's a kind of moot point whether they will serve him. Everything is up in the air. And one person who absolutely does not have any legions is Cicero. And basically the only weapon he has is his powers of oratory.
所以我的问题是，阴谋者是否有任何可以调动的军队储备，以便在城市中恢复秩序并实施戒严令什么的，还是他们甚至根本没有考虑过这一点？他们有的，呃，台伯河岛上有一个军团，由雷必达指挥，是的，雷必达当然是凯撒的骑兵长官，他的副手，这对他们来说是一个威胁。但也有一些军团已经被分派给担任山南高卢名义总督的德西穆斯·布鲁图斯。然而，这些是凯撒的军团。尽管德西穆斯·布鲁图斯曾在高卢的凯撒手下服役，但同样的，他们是否会为他效力还是个未知数。一切都悬而未决。而绝对没有任何军队的一个人就是西塞罗。基本上他唯一的武器就是他的雄辩才能。
And he targets Antony. And there's a kind of inherent paradox in that because Antony is the consul. So he's the legitimate magistrate of the Roman Republic. And Cicero, as the self-appointed spokesman of constitutional legitimacy, is setting out to destroy him. And he wants him named as a public enemy. And what Cicero does effectively is he turns the consuls designate for 43. So the following year, who again are two Caesareans, a guy called Hirtius, who again served with Caesar. It's Hirtius who finishes writing Caesar's commentaries on his various wars. So it's Hirschers who um finishes writing caesar's commentaries on his various wars so it's hirschers probably who writes the account of caesar in alexandria when he meets cleopatra and a guy
他将矛头指向了安东尼。这其中存在一种内在的悖论，因为安东尼是执政官。所以他是罗马共和国合法的高级官员。而西塞罗作为宪政合法性的自封代言人，却正着手摧毁他。他希望将安东尼宣布为国家公敌。西塞罗实际上做的是，他成功把公元前43年（即第二年）的候任执政官争取过来。这两位候任执政官同样是凯撒派，一个叫许尔提乌斯，他也曾随凯撒服役。正是许尔提乌斯完成了凯撒关于其历次战争的《战记》的撰写。所以正是许尔提乌斯，嗯，完成了凯撒关于其历次战争的《战记》的撰写；所以很可能就是许尔提乌斯撰写了凯撒在亚历山大港遇到克娄巴特拉时的记述；还有一个家伙
called vibious panzer right um so a tank of a man tom a tank of a man yes and he succeeds in um turning them against anthony so it looks as though perhaps cicero is succeeding in rallying the causes of legitimacy legitimacy he sees against Antony, even though Antony is actually the consul. Now, all of this is, you know, these are figures who you would expect to be players in this game. But there is a rogue element that has been introduced by this primary heir that Caesar has appointed in his will. The grandson of Caesar's sister, a guy called Octavius, who at the time is 18 years old. And when the news of Caesar's murder reaches him, he's with troops on the other side of the Adriatic from Italy, getting ready to go to Parthia to serve with Caesar on the Parthian campaign. And he is told, you know,
叫维比乌斯·潘萨，对吧，嗯，一个坦克般的人物，汤姆，一个坦克般的人物。是的，他成功地，嗯，让他们站到了反对安东尼的立场上。所以看起来西塞罗似乎成功地团结了反对安东尼的正统合法事业，尽管安东尼实际上才是执政官。现在，所有这些，你知道的，这些都是你期望成为这场博弈中玩家的人物。但凯撒在遗嘱中指定的这个主要继承人引入了一个不受控制的变数。凯撒姐姐的孙子，一个名叫屋大维的家伙，当时他18岁。当凯撒遇刺的消息传到他那里时，他正带着军队在亚得里亚海的对岸，也就是意大利的另一侧，准备前往帕提亚参加凯撒的帕提亚战役。有人告诉他，
you are Caesar's heir. And his mother says, don't go to Rome. Yeah, whatever you do. You know, you have a large bullseye on your back now. But Octavius is a guy who, as events will show, is unbelievably ambitious and ruthless and able and determined um and he takes on the name gaius julius caesar from caesar's you know by the terms of caesar's will so he he is julius caesar when you get adopted you add the word anus to your name so octavius becomes Octavianus. And so he is known as Octavian. He did not call himself that. He called himself Julius Caesar. He wanted to forget all about Octavius, but let's call him Octavian. Octavian crosses to Italy. He goes to Rome. The story is put about by
你是凯撒的继承人。他的母亲说：“千万别去罗马。无论如何都不要去。你知道，你现在后背上画着一个巨大的靶子。”但正如后来的事态将证明的那样，屋大维是一个拥有难以置信的野心、冷酷无情、能力非凡且坚定不移的人，嗯，他根据凯撒遗嘱的条款，采用了盖乌斯·尤利乌斯·凯撒这个名字。所以他就是尤利乌斯·凯撒。当你被收养时，你会在名字后面加上“安努斯”（-anus）这个词，所以屋大维（Octavius）变成了屋大维亚努斯（Octavianus）。因此他被称为屋大维（Octavian）。他自己不这么叫。他叫自己尤利乌斯·凯撒。他想把屋大维这个名字忘得一干二净，但我们还是叫他屋大维吧。屋大维渡海来到意大利。他去了罗马。他的支持者们
his supporters that as he enters Rome, the sun is haloed by a rainbow, which is a kind of supernatural sign that, you know, the gods have blessed him. Sure, that definitely happened, Tom. Again, stories are put about that even as a boy, you know, he'd had superhuman powers that he could command frogs to obey him. So very Dr. Valverde behaviour. He's very effective at constructing improbable stories around himself. Because he has disguised the fact that he's, you know,
散布这样一种说法：当他进入罗马时，太阳周围环绕着一道彩虹，这是一种超自然的迹象，表明众神保佑了他。当然，这绝对发生过，汤姆。同样，有传言说，甚至在还是个男孩的时候，你知道的，他就拥有超能力，能够命令青蛙服从他。这非常像瓦尔韦德医生的行为。他在围绕自己编造不可能的故事方面非常有一套。因为他掩盖了这样一个事实，即他，你知道的，
he's 18. Yeah. But he has pals, isn't he? Is he got my seen us his, his great sort of his Alistair Campbell figure, his spin doctor. And a gripper is his,
他才18岁。但他有死党，对吧？他有迈克纳斯吗？他的那种阿利斯泰尔·坎贝尔式的人物，他的政治化妆师。而阿格里帕是他的，
you know, his kind of Gordon Brown who never, who never loses it. Right. Who always stays loyal. He doesn't throw staplers at people. So Octavian arrives in rome and then he he's testing the waters because although he's 18 years old although he's kind of geeky inexperienced operating in in a absolute kind of pond full of
你知道的，他那种从不失控的戈登·布朗式人物。永远忠诚。他不会向别人扔订书机。所以屋大维抵达了罗马，接着他在试探水温，因为尽管他只有18岁，尽管他有点书呆子气、缺乏经验，却在一个绝对充满鲨鱼的池子里运作，在这个世界里，作为一个18岁的年轻人，他根本没有任何权利去竞选任何公职。是的，我的意思是，这就是全部。尽管如此，他拥有两项绝对无价的属性。第一是他曾祖父的名字。这就是为什么他自称尤利乌斯·凯撒而不是屋大维。第二是财富，你知道的，金钱就是力量。他开始非常极其慷慨地挥霍金钱。很快他就与安东尼陷入了一种竞争关系。因此，当安东尼被要求交出凯撒的财宝以便将遗赠分发给人民而安东尼百般阻挠时，屋大维拍卖了从凯撒那里继承的一些地产，并用所得收益分发给人民，这显然让他变得极其受欢迎。他还用自己的钱开始招募
sharks and in a world where as an 18 year old he has no right to run for any magistracy at all yeah i mean you know that's the whole. Nevertheless, he has two absolutely kind of priceless attributes. The first is his great uncle's name. So that's why he calls himself Julius Caesar rather than Octavian. And the second is the fortune, you know, and money is power. And he starts spending it very, very lavishly. And very soon he's entered into a kind of rivalry with Antony. So when Antony is asked to hand over Caesar's treasure so that the bequests of the people can be given out and Antony's obstructive, Octavian auctions off some of the estates that he's inherited from Caesar and uses the proceeds to give to the people, which obviously makes him incredibly popular. And he also uses his money to start recruiting
私人卫队。很快他就拥有了一支3000人的卫队，3000名男子。他甚至率领这些人短暂占领了广场，这个被他招募的各种暴徒簇拥着的18岁男孩。他占领了广场，遭到驱逐后撤退了，但他依然绝对是个举足轻重的玩家。他不仅愿意使用暴力和侵略（尽管他已经明确发出了这种信号），而且他还是个精明的政治玩家，从他去那不勒斯找西塞罗并试图把西塞罗争取过来这件事上就能看出分量。西塞罗对他心存疑虑。但公元前44年底的发展让西塞罗确信，或许可以与屋大维达成一笔交易。
a private bodyguard. And very soon he has a bodyguard of 3,000 people, 3,000 men. And he actually briefly occupies the forum with these men, this 18-year-old boy surrounded by all his thugs that he's recruited. He occupies the forum, gets beaten off and retreats, but he's still absolutely a player. And it's the measure of the fact that he's not simply willing to use violence and aggression, although he's clearly signaled that he is, but also that he's a kind of shrewd political player is that he goes to Naples where Cicero is hanging out and he tries basically to win Cicero over. And Cicero is suspicious of him. But developments towards the end of 44 persuade Cicero that perhaps there's a deal to be done with Octavian.
因为基本上在公元前44年底发生的事情是，随着安东尼执政官任期即将结束，因而他作为国家最高级长官所持有的合法性也随之告一段落，他决定向北进发并在那里招募军队。但问题是，德西穆斯·布鲁图斯也有着完全相同的计划。所以某种程度上，安东尼凭借他名字的威望能够招募军团。但布鲁图斯——德西穆斯·布鲁图斯——也拥有一些军团。面对安东尼，他据守在北意大利的穆蒂那（即摩德纳）。安东尼驻扎在他面前，意图将他围困断粮，对他实施围城。而且，你知道，就是这样。
Because basically what has happened towards the end of 44 is that as Antony's consulship draws to an end, and therefore the kind of legitimacy he holds as the most senior magistrate in the state, he decides that he's going to go north and try and raise troops there. But the problem is, is that Decimus Brutus has had exactly the same plan. So there's a kind of Antony with the power of his name is able to recruit legions. But Brutus has some legions as well, Decimus Brutus. And faced by Antony, he holds himself up in Mutina, so Medina in northern Italy. And Antony settles down in front of him and aims to starve him out, puts him under siege. And, you know, this is it.
内战再次熊熊燃烧起来。因此，身在罗马的西塞罗心想，我们需要军队。我们需要资金。屋大维一直在向他献殷勤。于是西塞罗决定，好吧，实际上，让我们试着把他争取到共和国和宪政的事业上来。因此，他在元老院大厦站起来，要求元老院不要谴责屋大维招募私人军队的行为，而是将其合法化，并授予他公开的荣誉。是的，显然元老院里的每个人对此都感到完全迷惑不解。西塞罗到底在搞什么鬼？但他把屋大维当成工具了，不是吗？他绝对
The civil war has blazed into life again. And so Cicero back in Rome is thinking, well, we need troops. We need money. And so Octavian's kind of been wooing him. And so Cicero decides, well, actually, let's try and win him over to the cause of the Republic of the Constitution. And so he stands up in the Senate House and asks the Senate not to condemn Octavian's recruitment of a private army but to make it official and to kind of award him public honors yeah and obviously everyone in the senate is completely bewildered by this what what on earth is cicero doing but he sees octavian's at all doesn't he he absolutely
是的。难道不有趣吗，嗯，此时此刻——所以解放者们已经消失去了东方，不是吗？安东尼正在围攻德西穆斯·布鲁图斯，但元老院已经反对他了。西塞罗也反对他。好吧，西塞罗正在努力让元老院反对他。他正努力让他们宣布安东尼为国家公敌，但他们还没这么做。他们会这么做吗？嗯，我们会看到的。但他确实说服了他们，将屋大维招募的这支私人军队合法化，并将他编入许尔提乌斯和潘萨的部队中。当时（公元前44年转为公元前43年），他们二人于1月1日就任执政官。但即便在做这件事的同时，西塞罗也非常容易说出一些致命的俏皮话。因此，他在元老院大肆吹捧屋大维的同时，却这样评价他：这个年轻人应当受到赞誉、歌颂，然后像凯撒那样被送上高空——也就是说，被谋杀。他公开这么说了。他私下里也这么说了，但这个笑话传到了屋大维的耳朵里，屋大维，你知道的，
does and isn't it interesting that um at this point so the the liberators have disappeared off to the east haven't they they? Antony is besieging Decimus Brutus, but the Senate has turned against him. Cicero is against him. Well, Cicero is working to turn the Senate against him. He's working to get them to name Antony a public enemy, but they haven't yet done that. And do they do it? Well, we'll see. But he does persuade them to legitimize this private army that Octavian has recruited and to enroll him in the forces of Hirsus and Panza, who, you know, when 44 becomes 43, become the consuls on the 1st
把它记在心里，表面上接受了自己作为两位执政官的所谓中尉的角色，
of January. But even as he's doing this, Cicero is terribly prone to making fatal witticisms. And so he says of Octavian, even as he's bigging him up in the Senate, he says, this young man should be lauded, glorified, and then raised to the skies in the way that Caesar had been raised to the skies, i.e. murdered. He says that publicly. He says it privately, but it's a joke that reaches Octavian's ears and Octavian, you know, puts it away and accepts his role as someone who's going supposedly as a, you know, a kind of lieutenant to the two consuls,
但他并没有忘记这件事。所以公元前43年春天，战事季节的开始，许尔提乌斯和潘萨向穆蒂那推进，试图从安东尼手中解围。为了让戈登·卡雷拉（Gordon Carrera）知道，许尔提乌斯和潘萨是通过信鸽进行通信的。因为安东尼的军队挡了他们的路。
but he doesn't forget it. So spring 43, the beginning of the campaigning season, Herschus and Panzer advance on Mutina to try and relieve it from Antony. Herschus and Panzer, please Gordon Carrera to know, communicate by pigeon. Because Antony's troops are in their way.
在一个叫做福鲁姆·加洛鲁姆（Forum Gallorum）的地方，安东尼攻击了潘萨，在第一天的战斗中占了上风。潘萨受了重伤。但在第二天，他遭到许尔提乌斯的伏击，不得不撤退。当安东尼在战斗中战败并向北撤退的消息传到元老院时，正是这个消息说服了他们宣布安东尼为国家公敌。所以他们就是在那时迈出了这致命的一步。但随后他们得到了一个非常糟糕的消息，那就是许尔提乌斯在战斗中阵亡，而潘萨不久后也因伤势过重而死。
At a place called Forum Galorum, Antony attacks Panzer, has the better of the first day's fighting. Panzer is very badly wounded. But then on the second day, he's ambushed by Hirsius and has to retreat. And the news of this, that Antony has been beaten in battle and has retreated northwards, when it's brought to the Senate, it's what persuades them to declare him a public enemy. So that's when they take that fateful step. But they then get very bad news, which is that Herschel has died in battle and Panzer shortly afterwards dies of his wounds.
所以突然之间连执政官都没有了，背景里只剩下了窥伺的屋大维。与此同时，安东尼逃到了高卢，并在那里与雷必达会合。雷必达拥有七个军团，安东尼也拥有大量的军团。这两个人、两支军队开始联手。德西穆斯意识到自己彻底完了，
So suddenly there are no consuls and there's only Octavian lurking in the background. Meanwhile, Antony has escaped into Gaul and there he meets up with Lepidus. And Lepidus has seven legions and Antony has a large number of legions as well. And the two men, the two armies kind of fraternise. Decimus, realising that he's completely sunk,
他根本无法同时对抗雷必达和安东尼。他溜走了，试图穿过阿尔卑斯山北部去东方与解放者会合，却被一个高卢酋长抓获，交出并处决了。所以这就是他的结局。这意味着现在罗马与安东尼、雷必达庞大军队之间，只剩下屋大维和他的军队了。而在那个时候，你会以为这下要动真格的了。
there's no way that he can fight Lepidus and Antony together. He scarpers, tries to make his way through north of the Alps to join the liberators in the east, but gets captured by a Gallic chieftain, handed over and put to death. And so that's the end of him. And so that means that there is now only Octavian and his armies between Rome and the huge army of Antony and Lepidus. And at that point, you would think this is the action now.
这就是内战。好吧，所以罗马的每个人都在猜想，他到底要做什么？答案在7月下旬揭晓，当时一名百夫长来到元老院大厦，要求为当时年仅19岁的屋大维谋求执政官职位。所以他比这个职位要求的年龄小了，什么，整整21岁。元老院的人们气急败坏地吐沫横飞，说这是极大的愤慨，质问他凭什么权威做这种事。而那名百夫长把手按在剑柄上说：“如果你不让他当执政官，我的剑就会。”于是8月19日，屋大维被正式选举为执政官。接着他出发去与安东尼和雷必达作战，只不过他并没有和他们打仗。
This is the civil war. Well, so everyone in Rome is wondering, you know, what's he going to do? And the answer comes in late July when a centurion arrives in the Senate House and he demands a consulship for Octavian, who by now is 19. So he's, what, 21 years too young for yes for the job he is and people in the senate kind of splutter and say this is an outrage and you know what authority are you doing this and the centurion puts his hand on the hilt of his sword and says if you do not make him consul, my sword will. And so 19th of August, Octavian is formally elected consul. And off he heads to fight Antony and Lepidus, only he doesn't fight them.
他们见面并达成了一项协议，安排建立了一个三头同盟。这就是第二三头同盟。凯撒、庞培和克拉苏之前曾组建过一个，但那只是一项非正式协议。而这次是一个正式协议，尽管他们基本上是自己一手操办的。他们决定将他们的三头同盟权力维持五年，他们将对整个帝国的全境行使权威，他们可以无需请示元老院、无需请示人民，自行通过或废除任何他们想要的法律，戒严令被扩大到了罗马本土。实际上，在经历了400年之后，这标志着罗马人一直以来所理解的自由的终结。这是在直接强加军事独裁。
He meets up and they come to an agreement and they arrange a triumvirate. This is the second triumvirate. Caesar and Pompey and Crassus had done earlier, but that had been an informal agreement. This one is a formal one, even though they're kind of doing it themselves. And they decide that they'll hold their triumviral powers for five years, that they will exercise authority over the whole of the empire, that they can pass or annul whatever laws they want without reference to the Senate, without reference to the people, that martial law is extended to Rome itself. And effectively, this, after 400 years, is the end of freedom as
这种崇高而悲剧性的讽刺在于，那场本应促成专制统治终结、或者本应避免专制统治并将时钟拨回共和传统的单一行动，恰恰加速了它的到来并摧毁了共和国。因为在那个时刻，你依然有解放者们，不是吗？他们在东方。我们在本集播客的前半部分把他们暂时放在了一边。但是安东尼、雷必达、屋大维，共和国已经彻底死了，不是吗？元老院没有军队，那么他们能用这些权力和军队做什么呢？罗马
the Romans had always understood it. It's imposing directly a military dictatorship. The sublime and tragic irony that the one act that was supposed to precipitate the end of autocracy or to avert autocracy and to turn back the clock to the republican tradition, that that one act has hastened it and destroyed the republic. Because at that point, so you still have the liberators, don't you? They're off in the east. We've sort of put them to one side in the first half of this podcast. But Antony, Lepidus, Octavian, there is no way that i mean the republic is dead isn't it the senate have no troops so what will they do with these powers and with their armies rome is
基本上在他们和他们抵达罗马之前是不设防的。而在他们进入罗马之前，又出现了可怕的预兆——狗像狼一样嚎叫，狼被看到在广场上奔跑。天空中传来巨大的呐喊声。武器的撞击声，看不见的蹄声。这一切似乎都在预示着恐怖。天哪。所以，多米尼克，事实的确如此。也许我们该休息一下了。
basically defenseless before them and before their arrival in rome again there are terrible portents so dogs howl like wolves wolves are seen running through the forum. Loud shouts are heard coming from the sky. The clash of weapons, the pounding of unseen hooves. It seems to threaten horror. Oh, my word. And so, Dominic, it proves to be. And perhaps we should take a break.
以悬念结尾总是好的，汤姆，我们确实做到了。狼像狗一样嚎叫，反之亦然。这一切都在发生。接下来会发生什么？休息回来后揭晓。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。
It's always good to end on a cliffhanger, Tom, and we certainly have. Wolves howling like dogs, vice versa. It's all happening. What will happen next? Find out after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。在他的谋杀者中，几乎没有人多活了三年以上，也没有人得以善终。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Of his murderers, scarcely any outlived him more than three years or died a natural death.
所有人皆被定罪，迎来了各种各样的结局。有的人死于海上，有的人死于战场，还有的人用他们曾对凯撒犯下恐怖暴行的同一把匕首自杀了。所以，汤姆，你太急迫了。你一直缠着我让我读那段引文。那是出自苏埃托尼乌斯的《罗马十二帝传》。那是你自己的翻译，这就是为什么你想让我来读，因为你某种程度上觉得，不是吗，觉得在这期播客里你的声音还不够多？
All were condemned and met with a variety of fates. Some died at sea, some in battle, and some, using the very daggers with which they had done such terrible violence to Caesar, killed themselves. So, Tom, you're desperate. You've been badgering me about reading that quotation. That's from Suetonius, the Twelve Caesars. It's your own translation, which is why you wanted me, because you sort of felt, I think, didn't you, that there hadn't been enough of you in this podcast?
是的，确实如此。你想要多一点。所以基本上……非常符合凯撒的行为方式。你想自己说话，但当我在说话时，你想让我只宣读你写的东西。是的。是这样吗？
I did, yes. You wanted a bit more. So basically… Very Caesar in behaviour. You wanted to speak yourself, but when I'm speaking, you want me just to read out things you've written. Yes. Is that right?
是的。这就是朱利叶斯精神，这非常具有尤利乌斯·凯撒式的行为方式。好了，现在你可以用你自己的话告诉我们接下来发生了什么。嗯，罗马正处于这种末日般的境地，安东尼、雷必达、屋大维的军队都在那里，解放者们在东方，每个人都——好吧，我已经把他们忘了。接下来发生什么？嗯，所以我想要读那段特定的段落，苏埃托尼乌斯在那里阐述的想法——那是他《尤利乌斯·凯撒传》的最后几行——就是三头同盟安东尼、屋大维和雷必达觉得他们正在体现代币的概念
Yes. It's the spirit of julius this is very julius caesar like behavior all right now you can speak in your own words tell us what happens um rome is in this apocalyptic state the armies of antony lepidus octavian they're all there the liberators are off in the east and everyone's well i've forgotten about them what happens next well so the reason i wanted that particular passage to read the idea that suetonius is is articulating there it's the last lines of his biography of julius caesar is that this idea that the triumvirs anthony octavian and lepidus feel that they're embodying the idea that there's
是的。这正是尤利乌斯的精神，这非常符合尤利乌斯·凯撒的行为风格。好吧，现在你可以用你自己的话告诉我们发生了什么。嗯，罗马正处于这种末日般的境地，安东尼、雷必达、屋大维的军队都在那里，解放派远在东方，所有人都——好吧，我已经把他们忘得精光了。接下来发生了什么？嗯，所以我希望朗读那段特定的文字，苏维托尼乌斯在那里阐述的观点——这是他传记《尤利乌斯·凯撒》的最后几行——核心在于三巨头安东尼、屋大维和雷必达觉得自己正在体现某种理念，那就是……
that they are they are visiting divine vengeance yeah on the assassins of Caesar. And this is what is legitimating their actions. And so this is what justifies them in putting Decimus Brutus to death. But it's not enough for them just to kill the assassins and to hunt them down. Because what they need if they're going to go and fight Brutus and Cassius in the East is money to raise legions, even more than they already have. And the obvious source of money are the wealthy senators in Rome who are kind of sitting there waiting to be plucked. And there's an example in this from an early period in history where a man called Sulla, the first man to march on Rome, and he had issued prescription lists, which were kind of white boards put up in the forum. And so how this worked was that you would get a reward if you cornered someone who was on a prescription list and proved that you killed him by bringing his head to the triumvirs. And so this is what happens.
他们正在——他们正在将神圣的复仇——是的——降临在凯撒的刺客身上。这就是他们行动的合法性来源。这也是他们处死德西穆斯·布鲁图斯的合理依据。但对他们来说，仅仅杀死刺客并追捕他们是不够的。因为如果他们要去东方与布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯作战，他们需要的不仅是现有的军队，还需要金钱来招募军团。而最显而易见的资金来源，就是罗马那些富有的元老们，他们正坐在那里等待着被拔毛。历史上早期就有一个这样的例子，一个叫苏拉的人，他是第一个进军罗马的人，他曾发布过公敌名单，那是一种贴在广场上的白板。具体运作方式是：如果你把被列入公敌名单的人逼入绝境，并通过把他的头颅带给三头同盟来证明你杀了他，你就会得到奖励。事情就是这样发生的。
And it's absolutely kind of brutal and murderous so you all kinds of terrible stories of of you know condemn men having to kind of hide out in attics or stables that there are kind of shameful stories so there's a story of a woman who was um who hated her husband betrayed her portrayed him to bounty hunters and then married her lover the same day oh so that's that's not good behavior but then there's equally that many uplifting tales of wives who nobly stand by their husbands. And so there's one in particular who braves a beating from from thugs sent by Lepidus to beg for her husband's life. And he does actually survive. He gets off and he wrote to this this kind of moving tribute.
而且这绝对是残酷和嗜血的，你会听到各种可怕的故事，比如——你知道的——被判刑的人不得不躲在阁楼或马厩里，还有各种耻辱的故事：比如有个女人——嗯——她恨她的丈夫，于是背叛了他，把他出卖给了赏金猎人，然后在同一天嫁给了她的情人。哦，所以这可不是什么好行为。但与之相对的，也有许多感人的故事，讲述了妻子们高贵地坚守在丈夫身边。其中有一个人格外勇敢，她顶住了雷必达派出的暴徒的殴打，苦苦哀求保全丈夫的性命。而他确实活了下来。他逃过一劫，并写下了这段——这种感人的赞辞。
They covered you with bruises, he wrote, but never broke your spirit. So, you know, there are kind of inspiring stories that come out of this. But by and large, it's very, very brutal. And the Triumvirs make enormous amounts of money by wiping out vast swathes of the Roman elite. Now, there is one person, obviously, who Antony wants to see dead, and that is Cicero, who has spent the previous year writing escalatingly abusive speeches about him, kind of accusing him of being drunk, dressing up as a woman. Corrupt, I suppose.
他写道：“他们让你布满淤青，却从未击垮你的精神。”所以，你知道的，从中也涌现出了一些鼓舞人心的故事。但总的来说，它是非常非常残酷的。三头同盟通过消灭罗马精英阶层的庞大群体，赚取了巨额财富。现在，显然有一个人是安东尼做梦都想除之而后快的，那就是西塞罗。西塞罗在过去的一年里一直在写针对安东尼的、不断升级的辱骂性演讲，指责他酗酒、女扮男装。我想还有腐败。
Corrupt. All kinds of stuff. So Antony's very keen to have him killed. Octavian, of course, is ostensibly his friend and might have been thought to stick up for him. But when the triumvirs first met and agreed on the prescriptions, as a signal, as a marker of the way that they were all obliged to dabble their fingers in blood, each of them was obliged to sacrifice a man whom they might otherwise have felt obliged to save. So Antony agrees to the prescription of an uncle,
腐败。各种各样的事情。所以安东尼非常急于除掉他。而屋大维，表面上当然是他的朋友，本可能会被认为会为他挺身而出。但当三头同盟首次会面并商定公敌名单时，作为一个信号、一个标志，表明他们所有人都必须把手指沾满鲜血，他们每个人都被迫牺牲一个本可能觉得有义务去拯救的人。于是安东尼同意将一个叔叔列为公敌，
Lepidus his brother, and Octavian agrees that Cicero should die. And so Cicero heads off. I mean, he could have escaped. He could have escaped, but he's a natural vacillator. He keeps kind of going around in his litter, trying to work out, you know, where he should stay. And eventually he gets cornered by a troop of bounty hunters. He leans out from his litter, bares his throat in the way that a gladiator does when he's been condemned to death by the crowd and his throat is slit and his head is taken to Antony who gives it to Antony's wife Fulvia
雷必达同意牺牲他的兄弟，而屋大维则同意西塞罗必须死。于是西塞罗上路了。我的意思是，他本可以逃跑的。他本可以逃跑的，但他生性优柔寡断。他一直坐着轿子到处转悠，试图弄清楚——你知道的——自己到底该待在哪里。最终他被一队赏金猎人逼入了绝境。他探出轿子，像一个被群众判处死刑的角斗士那样裸露出喉咙，接着他的喉咙被割断了，他的头颅被带给了安东尼，安东尼把它交给了安东尼的妻子福尔维亚。
who has all kinds of personal reasons for hating Cicero and she pulls out his tongue and stabs the tongue with her hairpins and the head and his hands are then hung up in the forum and you know this mutilation of cicero's tongue perfect you know it's absolutely perfect symbol of the way in which the great tradition of free speech in rome has now been silenced and the hands that wrote the speeches that abused antony yeah are now severed and bleeding in the Forum. So Rome is in an absolutely terrible state. Meanwhile, what is happening in the East? So that line at the beginning from Suetonius,
福尔维亚对西塞罗有着各种各样的私人仇恨，她拔出西塞罗的舌头，用发簪刺扎那根舌头，然后他的头颅和双手被悬挂在广场上。你知道的，对西塞罗舌头的这种残缺，完美地——你知道的——绝对完美地象征了罗马伟大的言论自由传统现在已经被压制，而那些写下辱骂安东尼的演讲的手——是的——现在正在罗马广场上被砍断、流血。所以罗马的状况绝对糟糕透顶。与此同时，东方发生了什么？所以苏来尼乌斯在开头的那个观点，
the idea that all the assassins must be hunted down, this is something that the Triumvirs are embodying. But even before they form the Triumvirate, the idea that Caesar's assassins should be hunted down has been put into action. So Desmos Brutus is not the first assassin to be executed. He's actually the third. The first is Trebonius, who is the guy who had held Antony from going into the Senate House when Caesar was being murdered, and who had then been given the province of Asia in the kind of the meeting of the Senate immediately after the assassination. And so he heads off to Asia and he's followed by Dolabella, this kind of sinister, thuggish figure who has been given Syria. And Dolabella basically surprises Trebonius, takes him prisoner and hands him over to be tortured. And he's tortured very, very horribly for two days. And then his head is chopped off and placed beneath a statue of Caesar.
即必须追捕所有刺客，这是三头同盟正在付诸实践的事情。但甚至在他们组建三头同盟之前，追捕凯撒刺客的想法就已经付诸行动了。所以德斯莫斯·布鲁图斯并不是第一个被处决的刺客。他实际上是第三个。第一个是特罗尼乌斯，他在凯撒被谋杀时曾阻拦安东尼进入元老院，随后在暗杀事件发生后立即召开的元老院会议上被授予了亚洲行省。于是他前往亚洲，尾随他的是多拉贝拉，这是一个阴险、暴徒般的家伙，他被授予了叙利亚。多拉贝拉基本上突袭了特罗尼乌斯，将他俘虏并交出去进行酷刑折磨。他遭受了非常非常可怕的折磨长达两天。然后他的头颅被砍下，放在了一尊凯撒的雕像下面。
And this kind of serves as a warning to all the assassins who are out to get you. And this is given legal justification by a law that is passed by a guy called Quintus Pedius, who is consul with Octavian in 43. And so he passes the Lex Pedia, which goes back on the amnesty that had been given to the assassins and sentences all of them to death. And the assassins could not have averted this if they had stayed in Rome.
这某种程度上起到了对所有想要追捕你们的刺客的警告作用。昆图斯·佩迪乌斯通过的一项法律为这一做法提供了法律正当性。昆图斯·佩迪乌斯是公元前43年与屋大维共同担任执政官的人。因此他通过了《佩迪乌斯法》，推翻了先前给予刺客们的特赦，并判处他们所有人死刑。如果刺客们留在罗马，他们是绝对无法避开这一劫的。
So if they'd stayed, was Rome too dangerous for them? I think Rome is too dangerous for them. So there's no way that they had, so from that very first failure to secure the city. Everything follows from that. Everything follows from that.
所以如果他们留下来，罗马对他们来说是不是太危险了？我认为罗马对他们来说太危险了。所以他们根本没有选择——从最初未能控制这座城市的那一刻起。一切都由此引发。一切都由此引发。
And they've made this, they've disappeared. Now they've gone to the east presumably because the east is rich and they think they can raise troops. Is that right? And they do. And they've been doing it very effectively. So we shouldn't think that brutality and ambition is only on the side of the triumvirs. Brutus and Cassius both show themselves very capable of committing atrocities in the cause of raising money that they can then spend on troops so brutus you know he destroys an entire city the horror that he visits and encourages the inhabitants of the city to
他们已经这样做了，他们消失了。现在他们去了东方，大概是因为东方富庶，他们认为自己可以在那里招募军队。是这样吗？确实如此。而且他们一直在非常有效地这样做。所以我们不应该认为残暴和野心只存在于三头同盟这一边。布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯都表现出自己完全有能力为了筹集用于军队的资金而犯下暴行，所以布鲁图斯——你知道的——他摧毁了一座完整的城市，他带给这座城市的恐怖以及对当地居民的鼓励——
commit mass suicide um there's kind of emblematic horror when a woman is found hanged with a dead child around her neck and a flaming torch in her hand. And this is just before Brutus sees, you know, the apparition that we began the episode with. Brutus has also put Anthony's brother to death. He'd taken him prisoner and put him to death. Cassius, likewise, has been busy extorting money. So the traditional view, which is that you have these incredibly hard-nosed ruthless people on one side and these sort of naive you know bien pensant kind of dinner party people on the other is not really accurate at all no except i suppose brutus and cassius would say that they were extorting money from provincials whereas the triumvirs were were looting it from their own class it doesn't count
让他们集体自杀。嗯，当一个女人被发现上吊自杀，脖子上挂着一个死去的孩子，手里还拿着一把燃烧的火炬时，有一种具象化的恐怖。这就在布鲁图斯看到——你知道的——我们在本集开头提到的那个幻象之前不久。布鲁图斯还处死了安东尼的兄弟。他俘虏了他并将其处决。同样，卡西乌斯也一直在忙于敲诈勒索钱财。所以传统观点认为，一边是极其冷酷无情的人，另一边是某种天真、品味高尚的晚宴聚会般的人，这种看法其实一点也不准确。不，不过我想布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯会说他们是在向行省居民勒索钱财，而三头同盟则是在抢劫他们自己的阶级。这不算数——
if they're doing it to you you know, Eastern provincials. I mean, obviously it does. It's not, it's not legal, but it kind of, you know, it matters less,
如果你对他们这么做的话——你知道的，东方行省的居民。我的意思是，显然这算数。这并不——这并不合法，但它某种程度上——你知道的，对于一个罗马人来说，你敲诈罗得岛或克桑托斯的人的钱财，比起你谋杀元老来说，显得不那么重要，
I suppose, to a Roman that you're, you're stiffing the people of Rhodes or Xanthus for money than, than that you're kind of murdering senators. Yeah. But it's, there's brutality and violence on all sides. And both men and both sides end up with a vast, vast armies. So Britain Cassius end up with 20 legions, which is, you know, just under 100,000 men.
我想。但是，暴力和残暴充斥着各个角落。双方最终都拥有了庞大无比的军队。因此布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯最终拥有了20个军团，也就是——你知道的——将近10万名士兵。
They've also got larks, you know, thousands of cavalry mounted archers. So, I mean, this is a huge force. Yeah. And so Antony Octavian in Italy know that they've, you know, they need to match, and they manage to raise a kind of matching force. They also have 20 legions. Antony and Octavian cross the Adriatic. They leave Lepidus behind. They send advance force across northern Greece into Macedonia, so what had once been the kingdom of alexander yeah um and they they try to block the assassins but um brutus and cassius are able to they kind of go around the the bottom of a very densely forested mountain and snake past and then they emerge near the largest town in macedonia which is a place called philopi and they divide their armies brutus commanding one cassius another and they block off the via ignatia which is the great high road that leads from the
他们还拥有——你知道的——数千名骑兵和弓骑兵。所以，我的意思是，这是一支庞大的军队。是的。因此在意大利的安东尼和屋大维知道他们必须——你知道的——与之匹敌，他们设法招募了一支旗鼓相当的军队。他们也拥有20个军团。安东尼和屋大维渡过亚得里亚海。他们把雷必达留在了后方。他们派遣先头部队穿过希腊北部进入马其顿，也就是曾经的亚历山大王国——嗯——他们试图阻拦刺客，但是——嗯——布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯能够绕过——他们绕过了一座树木极其茂密的山脚，像蛇一样溜了过去，然后他们在马其顿最大的城镇附近出现，那个地方叫做菲利比。他们分兵两部，布鲁图斯统帅一部，卡西乌斯统帅另一部，他们封锁了埃格纳提亚大道，这是一条从亚得里亚海通往亚洲的伟大干道——是的——基本上他们处于一个有利位置，因为他们有物资补给。卡西乌斯的阵地使他能够控制通往最近港口的通道，因此他们可以把食物和各种各样的东西运进来。而安东尼和屋大维则暴露得多，他们的物资补给要困难得多。因此，他们必须设法强行突破自己的阵地。至于统帅方面，屋大维非常缺乏经验。他不过是个十几岁的少年。安东尼显然经验非常丰富。而在另一边，布鲁图斯更像是一个政治家。但卡西乌斯也是——我的意思是，卡西乌斯——你知道的，大概会自认为在战斗中能胜过安东尼。是的。所以面对卡西乌斯的是安东尼，而面对布鲁图斯的是屋大维。
adriatic towards towards asia yeah and basically they're in a strong position because they have supplies cassius's position enables him to uh control access to the nearest port so they can have food and all kinds of things brought into them anthony octavian much more exposed supplies for them are much more difficult so it's incumbent on them to try and force their position. And just on the commanders. So Octavian is very inexperienced. He's little more than a teenager. Antony obviously is very experienced. On the other side, Brutus is more of a politician. But Cassius is also, I mean, Cassius is, you know, would be, would fancy himself against Antony in a fight, presumably. Yes. And so it's Antony who faces Cassius and it's Octavian who faces Brutus.
你说得对，屋大维并不是一个优秀的指挥官。他对这场大混战的“贡献”在于，在战斗前夕，他发誓要在罗马建造一座战神乌尔托神庙，即复仇之神战神的神庙，他日后也确实这么做了。但基本上这就是他贡献的极限，因为随后他就病倒了。于是他被抬出帐篷去接受医疗护理。这显然不是最鼓舞人心的事。但与此同时，安东尼非常非常警觉。因此他试图通过穿过一片沼泽来迂回包抄卡西乌斯——卡西乌斯的阵地，并试图切断卡西乌斯与大海的联系。这就拉开了整场战役的序幕。于是卡西乌斯的军队与安东尼的军队交战了——
And you're right that Octavian is not a good commander. His contribution to the general shebang is on the eve of the battle, he swears an oath that he will build a temple to Mars Ultor, Mars the Avenger in Rome, which in due course he will do. But basically that's the limit of his contribution because he then falls sick. And so he gets taken from his tent to receive medical treatment. And this isn't obviously as inspiring as it could be. But meanwhile, Antony is very, very kind of alert. And so he tries to outflank Cassius, Cassius' positions by going through a marsh and try and cut Cassius off from the sea. And this precipitates the beginning of the whole battle. So Cassius's forces engage with Antony's
而布鲁图斯的军队，尽管他们不需要离开坚固的阵地，但他们还是出击了，他们进攻了屋大维的营地并将其攻占。屋大维——你知道的——他已经离开了，但这对屋大维的手下来说是一场非常血腥的失败。但与此同时，安东尼击溃了卡西乌斯的军队，卡西乌斯自杀了。我的意思是，这对解放者或者说刺客来说是一个巨大的打击——取决于你如何称呼他们——鉴于布鲁图斯的指挥经验远不如卡西乌斯丰富，大概是这样。没错，但他们仍然有军队。不过这或许也反映出他缺乏经验，他坚守阵地三个星期，但随后他出来迎战他们，而且他似乎受到了他的——但他随后出来迎战他们，并且他似乎——
and Brutus's, even though they don't need to come out of their fortified positions, they do, they attack Octavian's camp and they capture it. Octavian, you know, he's already left, but it's a kind of very bloody defeat for Octavian's men. But meanwhile, Antony has defeated Cassius's force and Cassius commits suicide. I mean, that is a colossal blow for the liberators or the assassins, depending on how you call them, given that Brutus is nowhere near as experienced a commander as Cassius is, presumably. Right, but still has troops. But it's the measure, perhaps, of his inexperience that he holds to his position for three weeks, but then he comes out to meet them and he seems to have been pressured by his, but then he comes out to meet them and he seems
受到了他参谋人员的施压。结果他战败了，他也自杀了。所以幽灵，幽灵是一个罗马公式，我猜，是一个文学公式，它是你厄运、你的内疚以及诸如此类事情的一种预示。好吧，所以——你知道的，你们以布鲁图斯在进入亚洲时产生的这种幻觉开始了这一段，但确实有人看到了凯撒的幽灵。这同样是由苏埃托尼乌斯报道的。一个来自希腊北部色萨利地区的人来到屋大维面前，
to be pressured by his staff. And he loses and he commits suicide as well. So the ghost, the ghost is a Roman formula, I'm assuming, a literary formula that is a sort of foreshadowing of your doom and your guilt and all that sort of stuff. Well, so, you know, you began it with this kind of vision that Brutus has as they're crossing into Asia, but there is a ghost of Caesar that is seen. It's again reported by Suetonius. Someone from Thessaly kind of region in Northern Greece comes to Octavian
说我见到了凯撒。凯撒预言你会胜利。于是屋大维去了，并且——你知道的——不管这是真是假。我的意思是，谁知道呢？但这都是这个想法的一部分，即菲利比的这场大战——我不是拿破仑战争的专家，但我猜这是一场那个规模的战役——我的意思是，你知道的，有20,000到250,000人参战——我的意思是，这些都是极其庞大的数字——
and says that I have seen Caesar. And Caesar predicts that you will win. So Octavian goes and, you know, he's whether that's true or not. I mean, who knows? But this is all kind of part of the idea that this great battle at Philippi, which I'm not an expert on the napoleonic wars and but i would guess it's a battle on that kind of scale i mean you know 200 250 000 people engaged i mean these
但就这场战役而言，汤姆，我能问一个关于这场战役的问题吗？我们讲述这个故事的方式，所有人一直在讲述整个事件的方式，一直追溯到公元前44年以及针对凯撒的阴谋，我们讲述它是带着这样的已知前提：刺客们终将失败，因此所有的重点都放在安东尼和屋大维的狡猾与冷酷无情上，以及布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯在没有做好充分准备等诸多方面的天真和愚蠢上。但是拥有如此庞大兵力的战斗，我的意思是，他们的实力相当，而且出了名地难以预测。那么如果第一场战斗，比如说，结果不同呢，如果卡西乌斯没有被杀，
vast vast numbers but but just on the battle tom can i just ask a question about the battle so the way we've told the story the way that everybody always tells the story of this whole business going right back to 44 bc and and the conspiracy against caesar we tell it in the knowledge that the assassins will lose and that so all the emphasis is on the the cunning and the ruthlessness of anthony and octavian the naivety and folly of brutony and Octavian, the naivety and folly of Brutus and Cassius in not making sufficient preparations and all these things. But battles with such vast numbers, I mean, they're pretty evenly matched armies and notoriously hard to predict. So had that first battle, for example, gone differently, had Cassius not been killed,
我们难道不会完全以不同的方式来拍摄这两期播客吗？而且，哦，你觉得我在……是的，我想是的。我的意思是，如果三头同盟输掉了菲利比战役？是的。我的意思是，这取决于他们是否在战斗中阵亡。如果他们在战斗中阵亡，那么……这就相当于游戏结束了，不是吗？
wouldn't we have done these two podcasts completely differently? And, oh, do you think I'm being... Yes, I think so. I mean, had the Trinvirs lost the Battle of Philippi? Yeah. I mean, it depends whether they die in battle or not. If they die in battle, then... It's kind of game over, isn't it?
雷必达是一个毫无作为的政治家，正如他后来所证明的那样。而布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯完全有可能通过武力恢复自由。我的意思是，但他们是否能够做到这一点，我不知道。如果安东尼设法从菲利比逃脱，战斗将会继续激化，随之而来的战斗可能会彻底摧毁罗马帝国。这就是事实，我的意思是，你知道的，我们在本系列开始时以加图自杀为例。我认为这就是摆在卡西乌斯和布鲁图斯面前的模范。因为当然，卡西乌斯本不需要自杀，因为布鲁图斯已经赢了。他在布鲁图斯胜利的消息传到他之前就自杀了。所以他本可以活下来以待来日。从这个意义上说，有一个巨大的讽刺：事实上，加图的榜样正是毁灭共和国的元凶。而对于布鲁图斯的遗体如何被对待的记述中，也存在着某种历史性和高贵消逝的悲凉感。因此有两种截然不同的记载。在一种记载中，安东尼四处寻找布鲁图斯的尸体。他用自己的斗篷盖住尸体，以示敬意将其火化，并将骨灰送回塞维利亚，交还给布鲁图斯的母亲。
Lepidus is an ineffectual politician, as he will show himself to be. And Brutus and Cassius could well have restored liberty at the point of a sword. I mean, but whether they would have been able to do that or not, I don't know. If Antony had managed to escape from Philippi, the battle would have raged on and probably Rome's empire would have been destroyed in the resulting battle. It's the fact that, I mean, you know, we began this series with the example of Cato committing suicide. And I think that that is the model that stands before Cassius and Brutus. Because of course, Cassius didn't need to commit suicide because Brutus had won. He commits suicide before the news of Brutus' victory reaches him. So he could have lived to fight another day. So in that sense, there's a kind of great irony that in fact, the example of Cato is what dooms the Republic. And the sense of something historic and noble passing is there in accounts of how Brutus's body is treated. So there are two rival accounts. In one, Antony hunts out Brutus's body. He covers the body with his cloak, burns it honorably, and sends the ashes back to Seville, to Brutus's mother.
但在另一种传统中，布鲁图斯的尸体是奉屋大维之命被砍下头颅的，并被送回罗马放置在凯撒的雕像下。对屋大维而言，对于所做的一切，没有一丝一毫的感伤。我的意思是，这其实与瓦兰蒂尼没有太大关系，但他至少足够成熟，能够意识到菲利比发生的事情意味着某种东西已经失去了。从这一点可以看出，当俘虏被带到三头同盟面前时——你知道的，那些被俘的贵族们——他们向安东尼致敬，尊称他为主帅（imperator），将其视为击败他们的将军，但他们却诅咒屋大维。屋大维被视为恶毒、野蛮且完全不可理喻，对吧？嗯，而布鲁图斯和卡西乌斯的死，
But in the alternative tradition, the body of Brutus is beheaded on Octavian's orders, and he sends it back to Rome to be placed beneath Caesar's statue. And for Octavian, there is no shred of sentimentality about what has been done. I mean, it's not really very much about Verantini, but he at least is old enough to have the sense that something has been lost with what has happened at Philippi. And it's the measure of that, that when prisoners are led before the triumvirs, kind of, you know, the noblemen who've been taken captive, they salute Antony as imperator, as the general who has defeated them but they curse octavian octavian is seen as vicious and savage and utterly beyond the pale right um and brutus and cassius their deaths
就像加图一样，在那些在未来几十年和几个世纪里哀叹共和国终结的罗马人的记忆中，这种死亡赋予了他们某种尊严。因此，有一位在提比留统治时期写作的历史学家将他们作为最后的罗马人来纪念，并且——你知道的——一直到今天都有历史学家在哀悼它——嗯——罗纳德·西姆（Ronald Syme），这位撰写于30年代、以俄罗斯法西斯主义和作秀审判为背景的伟大“罗马革命”史学家说：对于菲利比来说，这一次的决定是最终的、不可撤销的。自由之邦的最后挣扎，从此之后，只剩下一场暴君们在自由尸体上的争夺战。所以屋大维，我的意思是，剧透一下，他最终击败了安东尼。他们两人最终陷入了更进一步的内战。屋大维击败了安东尼和克利奥帕特拉，
rather like with cato that kind of dignifies them in the memory of of romans who in the decades and centuries to come lament the end of the republic so there's a historian writing in the end of the republic so there's a a historian writing in the reign of tiberius who commemorates them as the last of the romans and they you know there are historians right the way up into the present day who who mourn it um so ronald syme the great historian of what he calls the roman revolution writing in the 30s against the backdrop of fascism and show trials in Russia. He says to Philopi, this time the decision was final and irrevocable. The last struggle of the free state, henceforth nothing but a contest of despots over the corpse of liberty. So Octavian, I mean, spoiler, he ends up defeating Antony. The two of them end up kind of fighting a yet further civil war. Octavian defeats Antony and Cleopatra
并在适时候被授予奥古斯都的称号，作为罗马的第一位皇帝统治帝国。他是否是一个统治着自由尸体的暴君，这或许是我们日后讲到奥古斯都时可以探讨的问题。但是，毫无疑问，几个世纪以来人们所理解的那个共和国已经不复存在了。象征性地，这一切聚焦于公元前30年的那场谋杀。那是安东尼被击败并自杀之后的事情。被追捕的最后一个刺客是一个名叫卡西乌斯·帕尔门西斯（Cassius Parmensis）的人。所以他们追捕他们长达14年之久。
and in due course is given the name Augustus and rules as Rome's first emperor. Whether he is a despot ruling over the corpse of liberty is a question that perhaps we can come to when we do Augustus. But, you know, there's no question that the Republic as it had been understood for centuries, is gone. And symbolically, that is focused by the murder in 30 BC. So that is after Antony has been defeated and committed suicide. Of the very last of the assassins to be hunted down, who's a guy called Cassius Parmensis. So they're hunting them down for 14 years.
是的，这有点像对签署查理一世死刑令的人的追捕。我刚才正是在这样想。这就像在1660年代搜捕弑君者一样，不是吗？是的，持续这么长时间真是非同寻常。彼得·斯托达特（Peter Stoddart）写过一本关于它的非常好的书，他曾担任《泰晤士报》编辑、TLS（泰晤士报文学增刊）编辑，书名好像叫《最后的刺客》，讲的就是卡西乌斯·帕尔门西斯。这本书非常好，强烈推荐。
Yeah, so it's rather like the hunting of the people who signed Charles I's death warrant. I was just thinking exactly that. It's like the search for the people who signed Charles I's death warrant. I was thinking exactly that. It's like the search for the regicides in the 1660s, isn't it? Yeah. Extraordinary that it lasts so long. There's a very good book on it by Peter Stoddart, who was editor of the Times, editor of the TLS, called, I think, The Last Assassin, about Cassius Parmensis. It's very good, highly recommended.
但这是一个极其可怕的故事。我的意思是，它是如此残酷、血腥、嗜杀，并带来了如此巨大的破坏。但随着时间的推移，当奥古斯都掌权时，成功的标志就是人们愿意遗忘。因此有一个故事说，未来将成为皇帝的克劳迪乌斯——正如《我，克劳迪乌斯》中的那样——他想写一本关于内战的历史书。奥古斯都的妻子告诉他：别写，别去碰那个。但是奥古斯都——所以我们有点稍微超前了，但屋大维成了奥古斯都。他成了最终的胜利者。但他从凯撒的例子中吸取了教训，不是吗？
But it's a kind of terrible story. I mean, it's so brutal and bloody and murderous and so much destruction. But in due course, when Augustus comes to power, the measure of success is that people are willing to forget. So there's a story that Claudius, who will go on to become the emperor, as in I, Claudius, that he wanted to write a history of the civil wars. And Augustus's wife tells him, don't, don't go there. But Augustus, so we're sort of slightly jumping ahead, but Octavian becomes Augustus. He becomes the winner. But he has learned from Caesar's example, hasn't he?
因为他没有——我的意思是，他的确担任了许多职务，但他最终没有被谋杀，因为他没有——他刻意展现出自己的谦逊与卑微，并假装自己是元老院的公仆，以一种凯撒或许没有采用的方式。这么说公平吗？是的，完全公平。是的。我的意思是，他非常深刻地把凯撒的例子摆在自己面前，是的，当然，帝国中的每个人——罗马人和行省居民——也都清楚那个例子。所以他们也知道不要去暗杀他，因为他们大概会想：我们可不想再来一场大规模内战，是的。但共和国已经死了，你知道的，共和国并不是被凯撒的刺客、或是安东尼、或是屋大维所杀死的。毫无疑问，现在有了事后的诸葛亮之明，我们知道共和国注定要灭亡，共和国已经完蛋了，这是因为罗马的扩张、它的财富，因为它获得了这个帝国，并且因为共和国政府的机器已经不再适合统治这个庞大、富裕、强大的利维坦。我的意思是，我认为庞培没有让自己成为军事独裁者这一事实表明，或许正是凯撒的独特性格、他的野心、他的天才以及他对共和国遗产缺乏感伤，
Because he doesn't, I mean, he does take lots of offices, but he doesn't end up murdered because he doesn't, he makes a great spectacle of his own modesty and his humility and pretends to be the servant of the Senate in a way that perhaps Caesar didn't. Is that fair? Yeah, absolutely fair. Yes. I mean, he very much has caesar's example in front of him yeah and of course everyone in the empire romans and provincials have that example too so they also know not to assassinate him because they think we don't want another massive civil war presumably yeah but the republic was dead you know the republic wasn't killed by
才是最终毁灭它的原因。从反面来看，这有点像1914年的欧洲，如果斐迪南大公没有被暗杀，几乎可以肯定会有别的火星被扔到这场篝火上，对吧？嗯，我怀疑共和制的政府体制已经变得过于不稳定而无法持久，并且在某个时刻——你知道的——总会有人去做凯撒最终所做的事情，是的。嗯，我认为罗马的幸运在于，屋大维——我们一直把他描绘成这种冰冷的恐怖分子，而他确实就是这样——我的意思是，他是一个可怕的人物——他从一开始就很明显地把让自己成为罗马国家主人作为唯一的、唯一的目标——但他是如此极其杰出的政治家。我们不是已经说过这个了吗？
the assassins of caesar or by Antony or by Octavian. Surely the Republic was, we know now with the benefit of hindsight, that the Republic was doomed, was finished because of Rome's expansion, its wealth, because it had acquired this empire and because the machinery of Republican government was no longer appropriate to govern this great, wealthy, powerful leviathan. I mean, I think the fact that Pompey doesn't make himself a military dictator suggests that perhaps that it's the peculiar qualities of Caesar, his ambition and his genius and his lack of sentimentality about the legacy of the Republic
以前说过，不是吗？这或许是西方历史上最伟大的单一政治人物。汤姆，我一直认为你对屋大维太严厉了，坦白说。我认为他在18岁继承遗产时处于一个真正极其困难的境地。他很可能会死——我的意思是，现实地说，是的，如果你是一个赌徒的话，那是最大可能的结局。而他没有死，然后他做得还不错——他确实成了一个独裁者，但就独裁统治而言，情况可能会比实际发生的糟糕得多。
that is ultimately what destroys it. Conversely, it's a bit like europe in 1914 if franz ferdinand hadn't been assassinated it's almost certain that some other spark would have been thrown on the right on the bonfire um i suspect that that the republican system of government had simply become too unstable to endure and that at some point you know someone was going to do what caesar ends up doing yeah um and i think it's the good fortune of of rome that octavian who we've portrayed as this kind of icy terrorist and and that's what he was i mean he was a he was a terrifying figure um who clearly from the beginning had as his goal, sole goal, the aim of making himself master of the Roman state, but that he was such a supremely gifted statesman. We've said this
但如果他在菲利比阵亡，他将被人们铭记为一个怪物，一个冷酷无情地背叛和谋杀、践踏了罗马每一个传统的人。然而事实是他活了下来，并最终成为了国父，那个声称恢复了共和国的人。有趣的是，尽管屋大维不如尤里乌斯·凯撒那么知名，但他其实是一个极具磁性的历史人物，以至于我们最终都在谈论他。但把话题转回凯撒，如果凯撒在公元前44年没有死呢？如果他听了卡尔普尼娅的话呢？历史会怎样？去追寻这种反事实的历史是一个完全徒劳的举措吗？我的意思是，这取决于他在……安息（Parthia）的表现。
before, have we not? Probably the single greatest political figure in Western history. I always think, Tom, you're much too hard on Octavian, frankly. I think he's in a really, really difficult position when he gets that inheritance at the age of 18 he's probably he's probably going to die i mean that's realistically yes that's the most likely outcome if you're a betting man and the fact that he doesn't and then he does okay he does become an autocrat but as autocracies go it could have been an awful lot worse than it than it But if he died at Philippi, he would be remembered as a monster, someone who had betrayed and murdered in cold blood, who had trampled on every tradition of Rome. And it's the fact that he survives and ends up as father of the state, the man who claims
我的意思是，远征安息并不总是奏效，对吧？但假设它比克拉苏当年的远征更顺利，比几年后安东尼的远征也稍微顺利一些。但这并不意味着——你知道的，他并没有征服安息。他或许赢了几场，也吃了几场败仗，战绩参半，但他可以把它包装成一场胜利。然后他凯旋。接下来会发生什么？因为他们仍然处于公元前45年、公元前44年时的同一种困境中，不是吗？即他太强大了、太富有。有什么办法能将他容纳在这个体制中吗？
to have restored the Republic. It's interesting that Octavian is actually such, although he's much less well-known than Julius Caesar, he's such a magnetic historical personality that we've ended up talking about him. But to turn it back to Caesar, what if Caesar doesn't die in 44 BC? What if he listens to Calpurnia? How does history, is this a completely fruitless exercise to pursue the counterfactual? I mean, it depends how he does in... Empathia. Empathia.
当时的同时代人就已经认识到这是一个问题。西塞罗在暗杀事件发生后记录下了一位朋友的话，我这是意译，因为我手头没有原话，但我进行了解释。他说：我们完蛋了。无济于事。如果连拥有如此天才的凯撒都无法解决这个问题，那我们这些人还有什么希望解决它呢？所以完全有可能整个危机只会继续拖延下去，罗马帝国的整个社会结构将开始瓦解。不过，屋大维的例子难道不表明这个问题是可以解决的吗？只不过可能需要经历一场血流成河的巨大浩劫才使得这一切成为可能？
I mean, evading Iraq doesn't always work out, does it? But let's assume that it goes better than when Crassus did it, that it also goes a bit better than when Antony did it some years later. But it's not a complete, you know, he doesn't conquer Parthia. He inflicts maybe a couple of defeats, suffers a defeat himself, mixed record, but he can portray it as a win. And then he comes back. What happens next? Because they're still in the same position that they were in 45, 44 BC, aren't they? That he's too powerful, too rich. Is there any way that he can be accommodated in the system?
是的，我想是的。我认为这有一种——血腥杀戮的绝对规模使之成为可能——是的，我想是的。所以我认为这有一种——血腥和恐怖的绝对规模是如此具有创伤性，以至于它起到了类似烧灼止血的效果，是的。而罗马的幸运——你知道的，这是罗马的幸运——在于他们最终迎来了欧洲最能干的政治家，是的，他稳定了整个局势。而暗杀事件总体上——你知道的，当人们讲述那个故事时，很有趣，不是吗？通常情况下——也许莎士比亚的实际情况略有不同。
So this is recognised as a problem by contemporaries. And Cicero records, in the wake of the assassination, he records a friend of his saying, and I paraphrase because I don't have it exactly to hand, but I paraphrase. He says, we're screwed. Nothing can be done. If even Caesar, with all his genius, couldn't solve this problem, then what hope have any of us got of resolving it? So it's possible that the entire crisis would just have grumbled on and the entire fabric of Rome's empire would have started to disintegrate. Although, doesn't the example of Octavian suggest that it can be resolved, but maybe it takes an incredible descent into bloodshed to make that possible?
但总的来说，我认为人们的同情心往往倾向于凯撒而不是刺客。你觉得我错了吗？我认为有一种微妙的感觉，即他们是他的朋友，却以一种懦弱而冷酷的方式，
Yes, I think so. I think it has a kind of, the sheer scale of the bloodshed to make that possible yes i think so so i think it has a kind of the sheer scale of the bloodshed and the horror is is so traumatic that it serves as a cauterizing effect yeah and the the fortune of you know it's the good fortune of rome is that they end up with europe's most able politician yeah who who stabilizes the whole situation and the assassination generally you know when people tell that story, it's interesting, isn't it? How generally, maybe Shakespeare's actually slightly different.
在凯撒无法还手的情况下将他击倒。这不是一场公平的决斗。他寡不敌众。他被背叛了。我认为从历史上看，这取决于你的意识形态原则是什么。因此，如果莎士比亚能够以一种他无法展示国王之死的方式来展现凯撒的刺杀——因为那会过于敏感——但当然，人们完全理解这个故事在那个你无法谈论谋杀国王的时代的魅力所在，
But by and large, I think people's sympathies tend to be with Caesar rather than the assassins. Do you think I'm wrong? I think there's a slight sense that they're his friends and they've, in a cowardly and callous way,
那就是它使你能够准确地讨论那些类型的问题。所以凯撒的谋杀是——如果你是一个法国大革命分子，那么你当然完全赞成它。你知道的，他们都自称为布鲁图斯以及诸如此类的事情。所以我认为这取决于你的政治立场。
they've struck him down in a way that he can't fight back. It's not a fair fight. He's outnumbered. He's betrayed. I think historically, it depends on what your ideological principles are. So if Shakespeare is able to show Caesar's assassination in a way that he couldn't show, for instance, the death of a king, because that would be far too sensitive. But of course, people entirely understand that the fascination of the story in an age where, you know, you can't talk about the murder of kings
我的意思是，现在，是的，我认为人们——因为这些问题已经变得不那么……我的意思是，描绘谋杀国王或是总统之类的已经没有什么问题了。所以2017年，我想是的，纽约中央公园上演了一部莎士比亚戏剧——你知道的，纽约中央公园那种例行的夏季莎士比亚演出——然后引发了一场轩然大波，因为凯撒被描绘成了一个系着非常长的红领巾的人，
is that it enables you to discuss precisely those kinds of issues. And so the murder of Caesar is, you know, if you're a French revolutionary, then of course you're all in favour of it. You know, they're all calling themselves brutus and all that kind of stuff. So I think it depends on your politics.
天哪。有着东欧妻子，皮肤呈橘色的人。对。当时引发了众怒，你知道的，这实际上是对特朗普刺杀事件的描绘。但事实上，为什么要感到愤怒呢？
I mean, now, yes, I think people, because the issues have become less, I mean, there's no problem with kind of portraying the murder of kings or whatever, or indeed presidents. So 2017, I think it was, there was a production of Shakespeare in Central Park in New York, you know, the kind of regular summer performance of Shakespeare in Central Park in New York, you know, the kind of regular summer performance of Shakespeare. And there was kind of great scandal because Caesar was portrayed as someone
因为正如你所说，通常人们的同情心都在凯撒这边，因为他被自己的朋友背叛了。是的，真有趣。你在那里对谁更有同情心？内心深处，我知道你想回避这个问题，但内心深处，你是凯撒阵营的还是布鲁图斯阵营的？我知道事情会走向灾难性的错误。是的。
with a very long red tie. Oh, gosh. East European wife, a kind of orange skin tone. Right. And there was kind of outrage that, you know, effectively this was a portrayal of the assassination of Trump. But actually, why should there be outrage?
我想有点像西塞罗，我对他们无法提前做长远规划感到绝望。而且我的确发现——我的意思是，凯撒是一个非常具有同情心、富有磁性的公众人物。嗯，我认为有趣的事情在于——所以我想真正施加影响的是这样一个事实：凯撒曾以极大的宽宏大量对待他们。当然，凯撒有着可怕的野心，他有时也会非常暴力和冷酷无情，但他本可以极其轻松地惩罚所有曾经支持庞培的人。然而他没有这么做，并且他是如此宽容——我的意思是，这相当罕见，不是吗？对于一个拥有如此强大军事力量的人来说。但正如我们所说，赦免你的敌人，就好像你是主人而他们是奴隶一样，这其实是一种相当具有侵略性的行为。我的意思是，当然，这比像多拉贝拉那样折磨他们两天要好，是的，但这并不完全——
Because as you say, often people's sympathies are with Caesar because he's betrayed by his friends. Yeah, so interesting. Who are your sympathies with there? Deep down, I know you're trying to evade the question, but deep down, are you team Caesar or are you team Brutus? I know that it's going to go disastrously wrong. Yeah.
你知道的，宽恕比对我们而言要承载更多意义，我想。好吧，汤姆，我告诉你当我们的敌人在英国夺权时，我一定会接受赦免，我对于接受赦免毫无羞耻心。但多米尼克，我们所有人都已经基督化了，所以——是的，这就是为什么情况不同。无论如何，我认为我们应该结束了。事实上，我们应该结束了，不是吗？伴随着一句台词——在“埃图，布鲁图斯”（Et tu, Brute?）之后，这可能是关于凯撒刺杀被写下来的最著名的戏剧台词，它是由我亲爱的朋友杰米·缪尔（Jamie Muir）的父亲弗兰克·缪尔（Frank Muir）在喜剧电影《艳后狂欢曲》（Carry On Cleo）中共同撰写的，其中凯撒大声呼喊：“无耻！无耻！他们全都知道什么是无耻！”再见。再见。谢谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
And I suppose a bit like Cicero, I kind of despair of their inability to plan ahead. And I do find, I mean, Caesar is a very sympathetic magnetic figure. Well, I think the interesting thing, so I think what loads it is the fact that Caesar had treated them a great magnanimity. Of course, Caesar is terribly ambitious and he can be very violent and ruthless, but he could so easily have punished all these people who had backed Pompey. And the fact that he didn't, and he was so forgiving, I mean, it's quite unusual, isn't it? In somebody of such military might. But as we said, that's quite an aggressive thing to do, to pardon your enemies as though you're the master and they're the slave. I mean, of course, it's better than torturing them to death for two days yes as dolla bella did but it's not quite as you
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前体验——本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
know forgiveness is more loaded than for us i think well tom i tell you when our enemies seize power in britain i'm i'm taking the pardon i have no shame in taking the pardon but dominic we have all been christianized so yeah that's that's why it's different. Anyway, I think we should end it. Actually, we should end it, shouldn't we, with a name check of after Et tu Brute, what is probably the most famous dramatic line written about Caesar's assassination, which was co-written by the father of my dear friend, Jamie Muir, Frank Muir, in Carry On Cleo, where Caesar cries out, infamy, infamy. They've all got it, infamy. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com.
你知道，原谅在当时比对我们来说意义更重、包袱更沉重。我想，汤姆，我跟你讲，当我们的敌人在英国夺取政权时，我——我肯定会接受赦免，我接受赦免绝不觉得羞耻。但多米尼克，我们都被基督教化了，所以，是的，这就是不同之处。总之，我觉得我们该结束了。其实，我们真的该结束了，对吧？用一句紧接着“Et tu, Brute”（布鲁图斯，还有你吗）之后、关于凯撒遇刺最著名的戏剧台词来收尾。这句台词是由我亲爱的朋友杰米·缪尔的父亲弗兰克·缪尔在电影《埃及艳后外传》（Carry On Cleo）中共同编剧的，凯撒在剧中大喊：“恶名，恶名！他们全都知道，恶名昭彰！”再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、精彩评论和一点点八卦的固定去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和提前体验……本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。